[music]
>> My dear brothers, I welcome all of you
with Islamic greetings. As-salamu
alaykum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
May the peace, mercy, and blessings of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, of almighty
God, be upon all of you.
The topic of my talk is
characteristics of a da'ee.
To begin with, let me ask you a
question.
Who, according to you, were the best
people who ever walked on the face of
the earth?
Can anyone?
The prophets, the anbiya.
The anbiya, the prophets of Allah
tabaraka wa ta'ala, the messengers of
Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala, they were the
best of human beings and the best of
role models that walked on the face of
the earth.
And all the anbiya,
right from the time of Adam alayhis
salatu was-salam till the last and the
final messenger, Prophet Muhammad, peace
be upon him, they were given only one
instruction.
The instruction which Allah tabaraka wa
ta'ala mentions in the Quran, in surat
al-anbiya, chapter number 21, verse
number 25, Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala
says,
"That oh prophet, there is none worthy
of worship but Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala."
Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala in this verse
of the glorious Quran, of surat
al-anbiya, chapter 21, verse number 25,
informs us
that all the nations that which came
before and the messengers that which
were sent to them, they were given one
instruction.
The instruction was to invite the people
towards the worship of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala.
We in fact Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala
mentions
in surat al-ahzab, chapter 33, verse
number 46,
addressing the Prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam, Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala says,
"Wa da'iyan ila Allahi bi idhnihi
sirajan munira." That oh prophet, you
are a da'ee ila Allah.
You have been chosen as a da'ee of Allah
by the will of Allah and you are an
illuminating light.
So,
the basic point is that all the
messengers of Allah, all the prophets of
Allah, including the messenger salallahu
alayhi wasallam, they were all da'ees of
Allah.
They invited the people towards the way
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So, as Muslims,
we are fortunate.
We have been given this noble duty
that if we fulfill this duty towards the
cause of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, then
you and I, inshallah tabaraka wa ta'ala,
are doing the job of a prophet of Allah.
The best of human beings who walked on
the face of the earth were da'ees.
And if Allah is giving you that
opportunity to be a da'ee of Allah,
so imagine
what a great fortune you have acquired.
You know, people think if you become a
millionaire,
you earned a big fortune. You become a
big businessman,
you have earned a big fortune. Oh, I've
become a doctor, the most noble
profession.
Is that all? But they fail to understand
that the most noble and the best
profession
which all the anbiya did was a
profession, was the job of a da'ee of
Allah.
But
before we embark
into this journey or into this very
important duty of conveying the message
of Allah, we should all remember that
there are certain firm pillars, some
firm foundations on which our da'wah
should be based.
If these pillars are not in its place,
if the foundations are weak, then our
call may not be effective.
We may not become an effective da'ee.
Instead, all our hard work and efforts
would go into vain.
So, in this short talk of mine,
I will just be touching the surface.
As Dr. Zakir Naik said, the dust of the
surface.
Because if you want, you can speak for a
day together only on the characteristics
of a da'ee.
But inshallah, in the limited time that
I have, I'll be focusing on the very
most important pillars, the very most
important foundations on which your call
to Allah should be based upon.
Number one
is ikhlas.
It's sincerity.
Any act of worship that which you do,
it should be sincerely for the sake of
Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala. If you do not
have the sincerity towards Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, then in its very
beginning,
your call to Allah is a failure.
If you want to give da'wah ila Allah for
fame,
for popularity,
for earning money,
then the very beginning of your da'wah
is a big failure.
And Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala demands
from us. Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala tells
in surat al-anam, chapter number six,
verse number 162, that "Qul inna salati
wa nusuki wa mahyaya wa mamati lillahi
rabbil alameen."
Say,
"Verily, my salah, my sacrifice, my
life, and my death is only for the sake
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala."
If
this noble act of da'wah, the duty that
the prophets of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala carried forth, if
your intention is not to please Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, not to fulfill the
duty that which Allah has obliged on
you, then know, my brothers, your da'wah
fails in its very first step.
So, the most important
for a da'ee of Allah is that he has to
rectify his intention.
He has to be sincere towards the call of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And to
re-emphasize this, Rasulullah salallahu
alayhi wasallam said in a very popular
hadith of Sahih al-Bukhari, volume
number one, hadith number one,
he said, "Innamal a'malu binniyat."
Actions are judged by your intentions.
"Wa innama li kulli imri'in ma nawa."
And everyone would be rewarded based on
what his intentions were.
So, it's not the act that which you do
which is important,
it is your intention, what is within
you,
that makes the difference.
So, this was number one.
Number two
is
acquiring knowledge.
If a da'ee of Allah does not have the
knowledge to convey the message of
Allah, then he will not be calling
people towards the path of Allah. He
will be taking the person to the path of
the shaytan.
He will not be in a position
to differ between right and wrong. He
himself is not sure. He himself is
doubtful and he will lead the others
also astray. So, it is very important
for a da'ee of Allah
to acquire knowledge before he preaches.
And Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala says in the
glorious Quran, in surat Yusuf, chapter
number 12, verse number 108, Allah says,
"Qul hadhihi sabili ad'u ila Allahi ala
basirah."
Say, "I call the people towards the path
of Allah, towards the way of Allah with
basirah."
And basirah is a very comprehensive word
in Arabic.
And it can be roughly translated to us
sure knowledge.
Knowledge
which you're sure about.
You don't have doubts.
So, acquiring knowledge before conveying
the message of Islam is a necessity, is
one of the firm pillars of da'wah. But
that does not mean that everyone has to
reach the level of Sheikh ibn Baz,
Sheikh Uthaymeen, or Sheikh Nasiruddin
Albani. May Allah have mercy on them.
No, that isn't expected.
It would be the best
if you can go and reach that level of
these great scholars, but
the call to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
doesn't mean that you acquire knowledge
to a certain academic qualification and
only then you speak. No.
The Hadith of Rasul sallallahu alaihi
wasallam clarifies this point when he
said, it's a Hadith mentioned in Sahih
al-Bukhari, volume number four, Hadith
number 3461. He said, "Ballighu anni
walau ayah."
Convey from me even if it be one ayah.
So, as a da'i,
if you know that this
thing what I'm speaking or what I'm
conveying to the people is from the book
of Allah, is from the Sunnah of the
Messenger sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
then you are required,
you are obliged to convey to the others.
>> [music]
[music]
[singing]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [chanting]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.